tell us a bit more about these charges
and as they relate to the some 19 000
children that Ukraine believes have been
deported
yes well Russia contests that 19 000
figure but it does admit that it has
removed children from Don bass and from
orphanages elsewhere also in calzone
region in its words to try and take them
away from active War zones uh the
ukrainians have just
issued an arrest warrant for Apparently
one Russian politician and two supposed
Ukrainian collaborate collaborators on
war crimes charges for having been
involved in the deportation they say of
children from an offerage orphanage
around the southern Ukrainian city of
Carson when Russia Was preparing to
withdraw from there back in September
and October and they say that those
children aged between one and four have
been removed to Russia and some of them
are impossible to track Sergey lavrov
today in his press conference said we
have taken children away Russia's
argument is always that they are put
under guardianship not adopted and that
it is perfectly possible the names are
public for Ukrainian families
um to come and get their children back
if they want to I think the reality of
that is that the numbers are far more
than the Russians suggest even if they
may be far less than what the ukrainians
argue and that it actually is extremely
complicated and difficult to get these
children back from Russian guardianship
adoption orphanages uh Holiday Homes
wherever it is that they have ended up
and of course that is why the
international criminal court has
indicted both Vladimir Putin and the
children's rights commissioner here
Maria levovable over on war crimes for
the supposed deportation of children
and what else did we hear in that um
Sergey lavrov press conference Diana
well we heard quite a lot but uh we've
heard quite a lot of that before you
know how nobody wants to listen to the
West's rules and logic anymore as Russia
tries to build its multi-polar world and
that the U.N security Council should be
expanded but I think some points that
you might find interesting for the
British viewer one of which involves the
screw poll uh uh family
um obviously they were the victims of uh
novichok attack in February 2018 March
um and Sergey lavrov said that recently
the Russians have asked the British
government again what uh has happened to
Yulia and Sergey scrupal where their
whereabouts are a sort of professed
concern about the well-being of Russian
citizens another factor of Interest I
think is that in relation to Saturday's
armed Mutiny
Sergey lavrov said that Russia always
comes out of turmoil stronger and he
said that in relation to Wagner's
operation in Africa these were
predicated on contracts between Wagner
and particular African countries and
those contracts have nothing to do with
the Russian State and it's up to Wagner
whether they continue I think there have
been a lot of questions of whether
Wagner will be continuing its um
mercenary activity in various African
countries a lot of which has been done
for the kremlin's benefit and he
suggested that Russian instructors had
their own uh dealings with governments
like the Central African Republic and
that those were under the auspices of
the Kremlin but the Wagner's contracts
were a separate thing altogether
Diana thank you very much indeed
bringing us up to speed there